the white house adding more fuel to the
fire as far left lunatics threatened to
terrorize supreme court justices a group
of radicals posting the home addresses
of the six conservative leaning justices
and encouraging protest following the
leak of the draft opinion that could
overturn roe v wade the supreme court
has a huge fence around it now and there
are growing concerns about security
threats and pro-abortion groups set to
show up outside of churches this weekend
like this protest upsetting a catholic
mass
with people wearing the red capes of the
handmaidens tv show but the white house
doesn't seem bothered
do you think
the progressive activists that are now
planning protests outside some of the
justices houses are extreme
peaceful protest
no peaceful protest is not extreme
activists posted a map with the home
addresses of the supreme court justices
is that the kind of thing this president
wants to help your side make their point
look i think the president's view is
that there's a lot of passion a lot of
fear
a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document
we obviously want people's privacy to be
respected
and hillary clinton is also inflaming
passions over the end of row
and any american who says look i'm not a
woman this doesn't affect me i'm not
black that doesn't affect me i'm not gay
that doesn't affect me once you allow
this kind of extreme power to take hold
you have no idea who they will come for
next
all right greg
it appears that the white house the
administration jansaki have no interest
in discouraging the protest outside of
the supreme court justices homes
first i would like to point out that
kaylee is making me think of my days in
college because you're like a big giant
highlighter i am still
i feel like i have to just take you and
highlight my speech how to be bright so
basically this weekend is like an
anti-mother's day right isn't it
incredible that it's it's it's so
surreal but i bet you 100 bucks judge
that if and when violence erupts the
people who lost their collective minds
over january 6th in which the only
person who died was a protester ashley
babbitt at the scene they'll justify
anything in the name of abortion uh
there's a base you know
what did uh what did jen say there's a
lot of passion and fear but that has
been generated by the dems who are
acting as though abortion is being
banned outright it's just being sent
back to the states the new york times
claimed it would be about 14
estimated decline in abortions um and i
know that's sad for people who are
really working for that quota but people
can get abortions and they probably will
and that's just the way it works the
problem is
i mentioned this yesterday there's a
filter of evil that the woke operates on
they when they disagree with you it's
not that you're wrong it's that you're
evil and that excuses all of their
behavior so you know if you're against
them then they can do whatever they want
that's how they justify the eat that's
how they justify the riots after after
floyd
but the republicans don't do that they
don't see the other side as evil they
see the other side as wrong so they're
less likely to get physical of course
there are there are extra you know there
are exceptions but the dems have um that
have the memories of goldfish don't they
know if they normalize this behavior the
right always learns from the left it
wasn't like the tea party just came out
of nowhere i mean before that you had
occupy wall street uh january 6 actually
came after
antifa uh blm right and also the riots
so there's there's this
if you normalize violence you're also
normalizing violence for the other side
so it would be best if your political
leaders would condemn this because i
hate to tell you you know it's it's you
know it it always we we're in this
cyclical thing and republicans activists
conservative activists they have an
internal braking system they don't lose
control or destroy things because
they're more prone to process order and
orderliness that's why you don't see
that's why these right to life marches
are so calm and so peaceful and that
there's no litter you're right i mean
it's because when you go to climate
change
protest they're piles of trash so it's
like there is
the right always has a bit more uh to
lose when it comes to the stuff because
you know they believe in structure but
obviously there's going to be exceptions
but i think that would behoove the
democrats
not to make excuses you know um caylee
the the
we hear about the rage and for some
reason the left feels not only entitled
to rage far more than the right and i
don't know if the right ever does it the
way the left does it but they feel
entitled to act out their rage that you
know it's okay for them with an
administration not saying anything about
justices in the supreme court there are
homes with young children catholic mass
on mother's day i mean you know these
people on the right are basically saying
look since roe was decided there have
been 63 million abortions and you know i
said that in the wrong time period
earlier this week but you know the
people on the right aren't going crazy
but the left fields are entitled to rage
and there's no sanction why yeah they're
green lighted by the white house so jen
saki got a second bite of the apple she
was asked this again today about the
violence and the protests at the supreme
court justice's homes here's what she
said during a gaggle she was asked
specifically does the president want
protesters to influence supreme court
justices so they uphold roe which
basically that question verbatim is a
crime if you look at us code to
influence a justice by protesting at
their home her response was this i
wouldn't say that the president has a
particular view on this exact same thing
she said about the leak he doesn't have
a particular view on the leak so
unprecedented leaks no view
protesting at a supreme court justice's
home no view i get jinsaki's leaving i
get she's going to msnbc she needs her
street creds there i get that they say
all kinds of outrageous things tiffany
cross said let's quote her exactly pick
up a weapon and get involved nicole
wallace analogized those opposing covit
restrictions to drone strikes
domestically on u.s citizens so jinsocki
needs a hot take she's got a hot take
here by literally green lighting a crime
and you can look up the statue 18 usc
1507 there's also a code of virginia
against protesting at a primary
residence she greenlighted a crime from
the podium she greenlighted a crime in a
gaggle today harold what's your take on
it i have
what is your take on this
well first glad to be back around the
table i think there are two things here
first off
no one should ever
encourage violence to make your point
your political point but is it is there
and i don't mean to interrupt i think we
all agree with that what about going to
a supreme court justice's home
it's wrong i don't know how how much
wrong more but well here's what here's
where i would be caution everyone this
happens across the board remember there
were abortion clinics that were blown up
by conservatives uh back back years ago
back in the 60s 50s and the 60s in the
country black americans in the south
were water hose and violence was by
people who had different political views
in them so there's a history of this
dissent is important in our country it's
understandable in fact it's
indispensable but what is not is
violence the president the white house
should should encourage anyone who wants
to protest to protest peacefully but if
it crosses the line that person or those
people should be prosecuted much like i
thought parents had every right to go to
every school board meeting and say what
they needed to say and wanted to say but
when you threaten a political official
an elected official you crossed the line
now the issue here with the protest and
and the roe v wade decision i think are
two different things if you have an
opinion on roe v wade express yourself
the court will make a determination and
decision here politics is behind a lot
of this i have a strong opinion about
this i think people should have the
right to choose i think there should be
limitations on abortion in the country
but roe v wade i think has worked but
this court will have an opportunity to
weigh in on it in june uh and the
american people will have to live with
that decision and we'll have to live
with the politics of it and hopefully in
the next election democrats will get out
and vote for those who share their
opinion but i would encourage no one
please don't cross the line and engage
in any violence before any elected
official any judge or any judge but
lawrence the problem is that the
president didn't say don't cross the
line don't do anything violent when
they're talking the language of the left
is you know we've got to rise up we've
got to let them know um
what other language that they were using
that's very forceful active language
there was none of that nothing forceful
from the president of the united states
there's nothing forceful from gensake
and as you remember during the campaign
trail he often talked about his
compassion and his religion uh and him
as a man being of the catholic faith yet
they're specifically targeting catholic
churches he hasn't said a damn thing
about that um to hero's point the
problem is not protests or evil even
peaceful protests or even the violence
obviously that is wrong it's the fact of
their view of the system the fact that
they feel like
protesting a judge should change their
position on the map that is the core of
what the democrats believe and we're
just seeing this at the supreme court
but if we remember this has been
happening all across the country
protesting judges telling the judges and
the jury that they should not listen to
the testimony that is provided for them
or read the breeze they want to tear
down the system and i think at its core
what the democratic party believes today
is wrong i mean we can talk about
protests all day they shouldn't be
protesting judges because judges should
not be influenced by protests and i
think that is the real issue we can ask
the question on january 16th the people
have gone to protest at the capitol what
were they going to undo there
oh i i i don't agree with january 6th
yeah i don't believe that
i just want to make sure we consider i
agree with you i happen to agree with
your point about the judgment okay hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else